En 2017 se celebran los 150 años de la existencia
de Canadá.
El día concreto del cumpleaños fue el pasado
1 de julio, y con este vídeo, entre otras
cosas, desde VisualPolitik queremos decirles
a todos los canadienses… felicidades.
Y es que, amigos, motivos no faltan, el país
de la policía montada llega a su 150 aniversario,
en plena forma. Porque si algo podemos decir,
es que Canadá es, hoy, un país que está
de moda.
Y sí, Canadá es la tierra natal de muchas
estrellas que todos conocemos.
Pero en los últimos años ha sido especialmente una quien ha puesto al país en el candelero
de la política internacional. Nos referimos
por supuesto a Justin….
No, a ese Justin no,  a Justin Trudeau, su Primer Ministro.
En serio amigos, Canadá cumple su 150 aniversario
siendo uno de los países más ricos, con
más calidad de vida y más admirados de todo
el mundo. No está nada mal ¿verdad?
Pues bien, la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es ¿Cuál es la causa de todo esto? ¿Cuales
son las principales características con las
que Canadá celebra este simbólico aniversario?
Vamos a verlo en este vídeo, pero lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es ponernos en situación.
Puede que no escucheis mucho hablar de Canadá,
pero podemos decir que este país no es cualquier
cosa, de hecho, es el segundo país más grande
de todo el mundo, su territorio, ojo, abarca
6 zonas horarias - sí, menudo lío - y...
¿cuál pensáis que es el país con más
kilómetros de costa de todo el planeta?...
Sí, así es… Canadá.
(Claro, que… cómo bien sabéis todos los
suscriptores de VisualPolitik, ni la superficie
ni los kilómetros de costa hacen que los
ciudadanos de un país sean más o menos ricos;
tengan más o menos oportunidades o disfruten
de más o menos bienestar.)
Así que… veamos, siendo así, ¿qué se
esconde realmente detrás del “éxito”
de Canadá?
Pues todo esto tiene mucho que ver con
los pésimos años que el país vivió entre
finales de los 80 y principios de los 90.
(Durante esos años Canadá sufrió estancamientos
y crisis hasta el punto de que en 1995 el
mismísimo Wall Street Journal llegó a calificar
a Canadá como “un miembro honorario del
tercer mundo” por su incapacidad para controlar
las cuentas públicas).
Desde entonces como podéis ver, han cambiado
mucho, muchísimo las cosas.
Podríamos decir que Canadá supo conservar
sus puntos fuertes y despojarse de todo aquello
que le estaba causando tantos problemas.
Y sobre todo, amigos, por encima de todas
las cosas, los canadienses han comprendido
lo importante que resultan estas dos palabras:
COMPETITIVIDAD E INTEGRACIÓN
(Tras estos años tan malos de los 80 y los
90 los canadienses se dieron cuenta de varias
cosas: por un lado que antes de pensar en
gastar hay que pensar en crear, y que para
eso hace falta inversión, empresas y comercio,
mucho comercio).
Dicho y hecho, hoy Canadá es la séptima
economía más libre del planeta. Pero si
hablamos de libertad no tenemos que quedarnos
tan sólo en la parte económica.
El Instituto Fraser publica un estudio, el
Índice de Libertad Humana, que mide tanto
las libertades económicas como las libertades
civiles, es decir, mide lo que las personas
podemos hacer y no hacer.
Pues bien, según este estudio Canadá es
el 6º país más libre de todo el planeta.
Para que os hagáis una idea, España se sitúa
bastante más abajo, en el puesto 36, también,
por ejemplo, Perú en el 53 o Argentina en
el 103.
Al final, lo sabemos todos, la capacidad de
las personas para crear y prosperar es asombrosa
cuando no se ven sometidas a gobiernos corruptos
y a todo tipo de ingenierías sociales.
Porque… no Canadá no es un paraíso fiscal,
ni nadie se queda tirado en la calle.
(Y para quienes lo estéis pensando, la minería
es para este país mucho menos importante
que para Perú o Chile. De hecho, con el hundimiento
del precio de las materias primas y del petróleo
de 2014 la economía canadiense apenas se
ha resentido).
Tal vez una explicación está en la fuerte
descentralización que tiene el país. Canadá
está dividida en diez provincias y tres territorios
que tienen tantas competencias que incluso
en 2017 tuvieron que firmar un tratado de
libre comercio entre ellas. ¡Tal cual como
lo escucháis!
(“El nuevo acuerdo de comercio interprovincial
espera inyectar miles de millones a la economía”.)
La descentralización aquí es enorme y eso ha
supuesto tradicionalmente muchos costes para
las empresas que no operaban en un mercado
único sino en muchos diferentes con regulaciones
distintas.
“En Ontario, la gasolina debe tener por
lo menos un 5% de etanol; Manitoba insiste
en una mezcla del 8,5%[...]”. The Economist.
La parte buena, amigos, es que esto ha funcionado
como contrapeso al gobierno federal y también
para alentar la competencia entre provincias,
y eso claro está es algo que favorece las
buenas políticas públicas. De todas formas
el nuevo acuerdo está llamado a tratar de
superar estas sorprendentes barreras.
Y luego como vimos aquí en VisualPolitik,
está la apuesta canadiense por el multiculturalismo.
Y es que, la verdad sea dicha, hoy por hoy
este país es uno de los mejores ejemplos
de integración de todo el mundo.
EL MOSAICO CANADIENSE
Pero… ¿en qué consiste todo esto del multiculturalismo
canadiense? Pues básicamente aceptar que
la diversidad cultural no es una amenaza sino
un patrimonio y una fuente de oportunidades.
Eso sí, siempre subordinada a una serie de
valores como la democracia, el imperio de
la ley o la igualdad de las personas.
Es decir, para ser canadiense y ser bienvenido
a este país no tienes que sustituir tu cultura
por ninguna otra, sino que tienes que aceptar
y comprometerte con todos esos valores que
si de algo hablan es de libertad.
(Fijaos, Canadá es uno de los países con
más población inmigrante del mundo, 1 de
cada 5 canadienses no ha nacido en Canadá.
Y este porcentaje en ciudades como Toronto
se acerca o supera el 50%. Y todo apunta a
que en el futuro serán aún más, porque
cada año ingresan al país más de 300.000
nuevos inmigrantes, una de las tasas más
altas del mundo).
Y... ¿sabeis qué? No hay problemas.
Sí, lo dijimos, la inmigración no es libre,
sigue un sistema basado en tres pilares: puntos,
reagrupación familiar y refugiados.
(De estos pilares el más importante es el
sistema de puntos que para conceder los permisos
de residencia y trabajo valora cosas como
tener una oferta de trabajo - lo más importante
- o tener una titulación o saber inglés,
por ejemplo).
¿Quéreis saber cual es el resultado? Pues
atentos:
Casi el 80% de los canadienses consideran
que la inmigración es buena para la economía,
lo que no es extraño porque todas las estadísticas
muestran que los inmigrantes, los nuevos canadienses,
tienen más estudios, trabajan más, generan
más negocios y consumen menos dólares de
los programas sociales.
¿Hay normas? Sí, pero también una cultura
de integración y acogida como pocas.
(De hecho, desde 1977 todos los ciudadanos
de Canadá pueden tener otra nacionalidad
sin restricción. Así que cuando una persona
emigra a este país y al cabo de los años
obtiene su nacionalidad no tiene que renunciar
a la de su país de origen).
Ahora bien, puede que si algo refleja a la
perfección el espíritu de este nuevo Canadá
sea su Primer Ministro, Justin Trudeau.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU, UNA ESTRELLA DE LA POLÍTICA.
Justin Trudeau llegó al gobierno en 2015,
prácticamente por sorpresa y con tan solo
44 años. Hoy es uno de los políticos más
populares de todo el mundo. Y en Canadá no
es diferente.
Esto es algo que las encuestas muestran claramente
(Por ejemplo, una reciente encuesta de Abacus
Data sobre el liderazgo del Primer Ministro
muestra que el 70% de los canadienses confían
en que Trudeau gestione bien la relación
con los aliados; el 63% confía en su responsabilidad
a la hora de tomar decisiones y el 62% confía
en que sus decisiones serán buenas).
Ya les gustaría a muchos políticos tener
estos índices de aprobación....
Ahora bien, la verdad Justin Trudeau no es
un político al uso, para nada. El Primer
Ministro de Canadá ha puesto sobre la mesa
un programa y una forma de gobierno bastante
diferente a lo que suele ser la norma habitual.
Un vistazo a su gabinete es toda una muestra
de sus intenciones y también de la realidad
de Canadá.
(De los 30 ministros 15 son mujeres, encontramos
a un excombatiente en Bosnia y en Afganistán,
a una antigua voluntaria en Níger, a exdirectivos
de empresas o incluso a varios ministros sikhs,
una religión originaria del estado de Punjab
en la India).
(La última incorporación, por cierto, ha
sido Ahmed Hussen, un refugiado somalí que
llegó a Canadá como refugiado con 16 años
y que hoy dirige el Ministerio de Inmigración).
Pues bien, sus prioridades políticas son
tan poco habituales como su gabinete. Por
un lado una de las apuestas claves del gobierno
canadiense es impulsar el comercio entre los
pueblos.
Atentos a las palabras de su ministra de asuntos
exteriores:
("Las crecientes barreras comerciales perjudican
a las personas a las que están destinadas
a ayudar. Frenan el crecimiento, sofocan la
innovación y matan el empleo. Esta es una
lección que debemos aprender de la historia".
Chrystia Freeland, Ministra de Asuntos Exteriores).
Más claro… agua. Por eso Trudeau quiere
firmar incluso un acuerdo de libre comercio
con China.
Luego, a diferencia de otros gobiernos, el
de Trudeau no solo rechaza el proteccionismo
sino que quiere impulsar el cambio productivo
de la mano de la inteligencia artificial y
la automatización. Nada de poner trabas a
la tecnología, que si algo ha demostrado
es que mejora la vida de las personas y genera
empleos más valiosos.
Esto parece fácil, pero no es nada común
de plantear y defender… los incentivos de
los gobiernos suelen ir por otro lado.
La otra gran prioridad, y tal vez el valor
clave del gobierno de Trudeau es su apuesta
por impulsar los derechos civiles y convertir
a Canadá en un verdadero referente internacional.
Fijaos en la fuerza de esta imagen, Trudeau
se ha convertido en el Primer Ministro en
encabezar un marcha del orgullo LGTBI.
O también el último programa anunciado en
junio de 2017, el que podemos denominar como
Política de Asistencia Internacional Feminista.
(Así es, el gobierno de Trudeau no ha tenido
reparos en reivindicarse como feminista y
entre otras cosas ha decidido que la inmensa
mayor parte del presupuesto de cooperación
se dirija a favorecer el empoderamiento y
los derechos de la mujer allí donde no son
respetados).
Es un símbolo, pero a veces los símbolos
son importantes ¿No os parece?
Símbolos y gestos como su postura hacia los
remugiados de Sinia. Atentos a las palabras
de este peculiar Primer Ministro:
(Pues bien, a día de hoy han llegado a Canadá
más de 40.000 remugiados sinios, casi la
mitad, por cierto, mediante patrocinios, es
decir bajo el respaldo de ciudadanos que se
comprometen a responsabilizarse del bienestar
de estas personas).
Eso sí es solidaridad.
Y, ojo, como lo cortés no quita lo valiente,
nada de buenísimo. El gobierno canadiense
ha anunciado intención de incrementar el
gasto militar más de un 70% de aquí a 2024
para hacer del ejército canadiense una fuerza
ágil y moderna.
Comercio, puertas abiertas a la tecnología,
integración, derechos civiles, seguridad…
A mi desde luego no me suena nada mal, sobre
todo cuando tenemos en cuenta que parece que
este gobierno tiene claro que antes de hablar
de gasto hay que hablar de creación de riqueza.
Bueno, así es como Canadá ha llegado a su
150 aniversario…. Todo muy bonito ¿Verdad?
Pues esperad un momento, porque también hay
sombras. Pero de esa especie de lado oscuro
o amenazas que se ciernen sobre Canadá os
hablaremos en uno de los siguientes vídeos.
No penseis que sólo nos vamos a quedar con
el lado bonito.
Para no perdertelo no olvides suscribirte
a VisualPolitik.
Por cierto ¿Qué opinión te merece Justin
Trudeau? Dejanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a like. Un
saludo y hasta la próxima.